so VidCon was fun so fun in fact that I
mostly forgot to videotape anything
except for this can you say hi oh and
also this I can't everyone daddy in but
you're like actually a dad and this
creepy shot from a distance footage of
Jack and Finn
so yeah VidCon was awesome and thank you
so much to the staff and the volunteers
and to you Hank I mean it was just so
fun but it was not restful for example
three hours before I left the hotel for
the airport to go home I was playing the
Saved by the Bell board game with you
and a bunch of other people head in
general I got very little sleep last
week fortunately I came home to one
child with strep throat and another
child who is 8 weeks old and apparently
a relative of the kinkajou because she
is small adorable and seemingly
nocturnal so I'm very tired however last
night at 2:30 in the morning while I was
up with Henry I had my very first
million dollar idea so like you know
about this but nerdfighters don't so I'm
going to explain it to them for the last
six or so years hank has called me on
average I'd say about once a week and
the first thing he says to me is I have
a million dollar idea
sometimes these million dollar ideas are
excellent like the project for awesome
or VidCon or dftba records sometimes
they seem terrible but turn out to be
great like 2d glasses and usually
they're just actually terrible like the
time Hank called me and said I have a
million dollar idea Hank games times two
it's just
Hank games sped up so it's twice as fast
anyway the one thing that all these
million dollar ideas have in common is
that none of them has ever made me a
million dollars in fact most of them are
about like charity but my million dollar
idea is different Hank it is an actual
million dollar idea I just can't
implement it because I don't know how to
do the programming of the apps okay
there's an app and you download it for
your phone or more likely your
teenager's phone and what it does is it
starts crying and you can choose
different ways to try to sue with your
phone baby like you can see
and give it a pacifier you can shush it
sometimes these things work and your
phone baby will go to sleep and then you
will be able to use your phone but other
times they won't work and your phone
baby will just keep crying and then you
will try to put your phone on mute but
no that is not allowed the phone maybe
will keep crying but then eventually
your phone baby will go to sleep and she
will sleep peacefully for two and a half
to three hours at which point she will
wake up and that will happen 24 hours a
day seven days a week for 12 weeks then
the frequency of your phone baby's
crying will slow down a lot but still
every few months something will happen
to your phone baby and she'll get upset
again and cry other than that the night
that you'll have to spend hours pushing
buttons trying to figure out my solve
you I know what you're thinking hey this
app won't work with iPhones or Android
phones or any phones because you can
just turn them off well Hank things are
gonna change in the phone world thanks
to my million-dollar idea yeah it's not
that good of an idea it's like all of
your million-dollar ideas actually it's
worse than yours remember when you
called me and you were like I want to
make 2d glasses
they're gonna take 3d movies and they're
gonna render them in a crisp two
dimensions but I think a thousand
dollars from you in order to start this
company and I said go suck it and now
Hank here you are two years later loan
king of a 2d glasses empire yeah let's
face the neck I'm never gonna be the
brains of this operation but I can't
tell you how grateful I am to be a part
of it thank you for being awesome thank
you for the gift of VidCon
dftba I will see you on Friday I said
both thank you for being awesome and
don't forget to be awesome because they
both applied really because like thank
you but also don't forget to continue to
be awesome that makes sense the FTC B
I'm so tired